Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Alright. Today's Maestro Hook.
A Hook is a good conversation piece you can use when you're talking with a foreigner,...
...when you run out of topics...
...or you need a good topic to make the conversation better.
Today, we're gonna talk about the word...
..."sportsmanship" in English.
We don't really use that word.
It's kind of a strange word.
Of course, we have that culture but in English it's called more the "one-upmanship".
One-upmanship means you go one-up than another person.
So, you want to one-up somebody,...
...whether in a game of tennis, you wanna win,...
...it's one-upmanship.
Or, when you're having a conversation and you wanna point something out,...
...and be better than that person,..
...it's all one-upmanship.
It's important in Western culture to have this...
...because you always wanna be better than everybody.
It's a very aggressive attitude...
...and it's the one-upmanship.
Okay, so English is connected to that.
You got me there.
Oh! You got me there.
Okay.
You showed him.
I showed you.
I showed him.
Yeah, you really showed him.
So, Maestro Lines.
I beat you in that game of tennis, didn't I?
Oh, you're right! You got me there.
Yeah, you're a better player than me.
Yeah, in that meeting, you really said what you wanted to.
Yeah, he didn't know what to say.
You really showed him.
So, this is a really important spirit in American culture, the one-upmanship.
It's a casual word but you can use it a lot in very good conversations.
So, please learn the one-upmanship like sportsmanship,...
...okay?
That's it for today and I hope you liked it.
And next week, there's more stuff that you can learn,...
...culture, and words that you can use to become a native maestro.
Alright, thanks a lot and see you later!